KEEP POURING THROUGH ALL OF
THAT.
WE'LL COME BACK TO IT.
GREAT JOB AS ALWAYS.
ED HENRY IN WASHINGTON.
JOINING US NOW ON THESE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS, HE IS THE HOST OF
CRT BEES "LEVIN TV," THE HOST OF
"LIFE, LIBERTY AND BUY LEVIN," T
"LIFE, LIBERTY AND BUY LEVIN," E
PRESIDENT AND THE OF THE
UNITED STATES, COMEY IS SAYING
HE DID NOT SHUT DOWN THE
INVESTIGATION, THE ASSOCIATES,
SATELLITES, PEOPLE THAT ARE
AROUND ME THAT DID SOMETHING
INAPPROPRIATE, I WANT YOU TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
I DON'T THINK IT GETS ANY MORE
EXCULPATORY THAN THAT, MARK
FREYD SPEAK OF THESE MEMOS
ACTUALLY HELP THE PRESIDENT.
THERE'S NOTHING INCRIMINATED
THERE'S NOTHING INCRIMINATED   I
THERE'S NOTHING INCRIMINATED   C
THERE'S NOTHING INCRIMINATED   A
THERE'S NOTHING INCRIMINATED   I
THERE'S NOTHING INCRIMINATED   G
THERE'S NOTHING INCRIMINATED   N
THEM.
IT TOOK 25 MINUTES TO DO AS BEST
I COULD AND READ THROUGH THEM.
TO SEE THESE REDACTED AREAS?
THE INCRIMINATED COMEY BECAUSE
HE SAID HE DIDN'T RELEASE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
AT THE BOTTOM OF A NUMBER OF
THESE PAGES, IT SAYS
"CLASSIFIED."
COMEY SAID HE DID NOT CLASSIFY
INFORMATION SO HE'S GOT SOME
EXPLAINING TO DO.
I HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS, THE
PRESIDENT IS FURIOUS ABOUT THESE
ALLEGATIONS ABOUT PROSTITUTES,
HE CONTINUALLY DENIES IT.
I WANT TO POINT OUT SOME BECOME
TOO, SEAN, WHICH IS THIS.
TODAY, THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY OF
THE UNITED STATES, ROSENSTEIN,
TOLD THE PRESIDENT HE IS NOT A
TARGET IN THE MICHAEL COHEN CASE
OR THE RUSSIAN CASE.
LET'S GET SOMETHING STRAIGHT.
I WAS ON YOUR PROGRAM BACK IN
JULY LAST YEAR.
I'VE GOT TWO MEMORANDA.
ONE, UNDER THE NIXON
ADMINISTRATION, ONE UNDER THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION.
THE CLINTON ADMINISTRATION
MEMORANDUM IS 39 PAGES LONG WITH
A ZILLION FOOTNOTES.
HERE IS IT SAYS, HERE IS WHAT
HAS BEEN GOING ON TO YOUR
COUNTRY.
THE MEMO IS ADDRESSED TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR MANY OFFICE OF
LEGAL COUNSEL, WHICH HANDLES
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES.
A SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE
ABILITY TO INDICT CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION, THE INDICTMENT OR
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION OF A
SITTING PRESIDENT WOULD
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY UNDERMINE THE
CAPACITY OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
TO PERFORM ITS ASSIGNED
FUNCTIONS.
PAGE AFTER PAGE AFTER PAGE
SAYING A SITTING UNITED STATES
PRESIDENT CANNOT BE INDICTED.
NOW MY QUESTION IS THIS.
IF THEY ISSUE ANOTHER MEMO OUT
THERE AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
REVERSING THESE MEMOS?
NO!
NO.
MR. ROSENSTEIN, YOU ARE THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
UNITED STATES.
YOU'VE BEEN OVERSEEING
ROBERT MUELLER.
YOU TELL THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES LAST WEEK THAT
HE'S NOT A CRIMINAL TARGET.
HE CAN'T BE A CRIMINAL TARGET
UNDER THE MEMORANDA THAT HAVE
BEEN WRITTEN BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT!
MOREOVER, JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
REGULATIONS REQUIRE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL OF THE UNITED STATES TO
FOLLOW THE RULES, REGULATIONS,
AND "POLICIES" OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
MR. PRESIDENT, DON'T YOU SIT
DOWN WITH THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL DOESN'T HAVE
THE POWER TO INDICT YOU AND FOR
GOOD REASON!
LET ME READ THIS ONE PARAGRAPH.
THIS IS FROM THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
IN 1973, THE DEPARTMENT
CONCLUDED THAT THE INDICTMENT OR
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION OF A
SITTING PRESIDENT WOULD
IMPERMISSIBLY UNDERMINE THE
CAPACITY OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
TO PERFORMANCE CONSTITUTIONALLY
ASSIGNED FUNCTIONS.
I'M HOPING PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ
IS LISTENING.
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO SUMMARIZE,
REVIEW THE INFORMATION IN
SUPPORT OF THAT CONCLUSION I
CONSIDER WHETHER ANY
DEVELOPMENTS LEAD US TO
RECONSIDER OR DISAVOW THAT
DETERMINATION.
ONE MORE SENTENCE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE CONCLUSION
REACHED BY THE DEPARTMENT IN
1972 STILL REPRESENTS THE BEST
INTERPRETATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
THEY ARE SAYING, MR. MUELLER'S
BOSS, MR. ROSENSTEIN'S BOSS,
UNLESS ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS
HAS REJECTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S POSITION THAT A
SITTING PRESIDENT CANNOT BE
INDICTED, SO WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> Sean: YOU KNOW WHAT THEY
ARE DOING.
THEY ARE     WANT TO SET UP AN
IMPEACHMENT POSSIBILITY.
THAT IS WHY -- TALK ABOUT
MONOPOLY OR ANY TYPE OF BOARD
GAME, HOW DO YOU GO FROM PAST GO
ALL THE WAY TO BOARDWALK AND
PARK PLACE IF, IN FACT, NOW IT
IS STORMY DANIELS.
I HAVE A MORE IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
LAST NIGHT, CONGRESSMAN RON
DeSANTIS AND TEN OTHER
CONGRESSMEN SENT CRIMINAL
REFERRALS FOR PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE AND McCABE ANDREW
McCABE AND COMEY AT
HILLARY CLINTON AND THESE OTHER
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THIS DOSSIER.
THEN WE HAVE THE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS TODAY FOR ANDREW
McCABE FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
WALK US THROUGH THE LEGAL
ASPECTS OF THIS.
WHERE THIS HEADS NEXT.
I KNOW YOU HAVE CALLED FOR THE
FIRING OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND HE'S A FRIEND OF YOURS --
>> NO, I DID NOT CALL FOR THE
FIRING.
I SAID HE SHOULD STEP DOWN.
I DON'T REALLY ENJOY IT.
I'VE KNOWN HIM FOR 30 YEARS.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
OUT OF CONTROL.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS HIS SHOULDERS
BRANCH OF THE WALL.
AS THE JOB OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO CONTROL THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE.
HE'S A PRESIDENTIAL APPOINTEE.
THIS IS WHAT OUR CONSTITUTION
REQUIRES.
AN INFERIOR OFFICER CANNOT USURP
THE POWER OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AS
MR. ROSENSTEIN HAS DONE.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU SOMETHING,
THERE'S A CASE THAT HAS BEEN
TAKING PLACE IN THE
PAUL MANAFORT CASE.
THEY WENT INTO DISTRICT COURT
AND SAID MUELLER IS EXERCISING
AUTHORITY HE DID NOT HAVE.
THIS TOOK PLACE TODAY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS FEDERAL
DISTRICT JUDGES GOING TO DO BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT SHE SAID?
THEY ARE MAKING A FAIR POINT
HERE.
MR. ROSENSTEIN GAVE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL SUCH A REMARKABLY BROAD
POWERS THAT IT MAY WELL BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
SO LET'S SUM UP.
FOR DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
MAY WELL BE UNDER CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE HE'S A
SERIAL LEAKER.
THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR MAY BE A
WITNESS AGAINST HIS FORMER
DEPUTY AND THE DEPUTY MAY BE A
WITNESS AGAINST THE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR WHO HE SAYS IS LYING.
>> Sean: OKAY.
THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO A QUESTION
I ASKED PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ
BECAUSE THIS IS IMPORTANT.
EVERYTHING THAT WE NOW KNOW
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON, YOU WOULD
BE MY BEST LAWYER.
I'D CALL YOU.
YOU ARE MY FRIEND.
YOU ARE THE GREAT ONE.
I CALL YOU THE GREAT ONE.
IF I DELETED 33,000 SUBPOENAED
EMAILS, ACID WATCHED THE HARD
DRIVE, BEAT THE DEVICES, HAD
SOMEONE ELSE DO IT, THAT WOULD
BE DESTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I KNOW IT, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW IT.
WHEN COMEY AND HIS TRUMP HATING
BUDDY, PETER STRZOK, WHERE THEY
WEALTHY EXONERATION BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION, WE KNOW THE FIX
WAS IN.
YOU DON'T WRITE THAT IN MAY AND
NOT INTERVIEW HER UNTIL JULY.
YOU HAVE A DOSSIER, YOU HAND
THAT DOSSIER TO A FOREIGN
NATIONAL, RUSSIAN LIES, TO A
FISA COURT JUDGE AND DON'T SAY
WHO PAID FOR IT, AND YOU DON'T
VERIFY IT, MARK, YOU HAVE SAID
THIS IS A POST CONSTITUTIONAL
AMERICA.
THESE INSTANCES VERIFY WHAT YOU
WROTE IN YOUR LAST BOOK HAS 100%
ACCURATE.
THESE ARE SCARY TIMES IF YOU
BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF LAW,
EQUAL APPLICATION UNDER THE LAW,
AND THE CONSTITUTION.
EXPLAIN.
>> THIS IS THE GREATEST SCANDAL
IN MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST ECHELONS OF
THE FBI AND A LOT OF FORMER FBI
OFFICIALS WHO ARE FRIENDS OF
MINE BECAUSE I'VE WORKED ON THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, WHO ARE
CORRUPT.
I DON'T MEAN ON THE TAPE, I MEAN
POLITICALLY CORRUPT.
YOU ARE SEEING THAT PLAY OUT
NOW.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY -- THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE GETTING A REAL TASTE
OF MR. COMEY AND THEY DON'T LIKE
HIM.
YOU ARE ALSO SEEING THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF POLITICS.
YOU ARE ALSO -- WE HAVEN'T EVEN
GOTTEN INTO WHAT THE
INTELLIGENCE SIDE HAS DONE.
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT THIS.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY NOMINATED
SOMEBODY WHO IS UNDER CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
MR. COMEY STEPPED IN AND
PROTECTED HER.
HILLARY CLINTON IS TOO STUPID TO
REALIZE THAT HE PROTECTED HER
FROM BEING INDICTED.
WE COULD HAVE HAD A CANDIDATE
FOR FEDERAL OFFICE INDICTED.
SHE CLEARLY VIOLATED THE
ESPIONAGE ACT, NOT ONCE, BUT
REPEATEDLY.
MR. COMEY SAYS YOU NEED SPECIFIC
INTENT IN A STATUTE THAT TALKS
ABOUT GROSS NEGLIGENCE.
WE HAD TO SPECIFIC INTENT.
SHE SPECIFICALLY INTENDED TO
HAVE A SERVER THAT WAS OFF-LINE,
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A SECURITY
NECESSARY, SHE KNEW SHE WOULD
WHO CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, AND
SHE KNEW SHE WOULD -- MR. COMEY
WAS A SPECIAL PLEADER FOR
HILLARY CLINTON AND THIS IS WHY
THE DEMOCRATS HATED HIM UNTIL
THE SECOND AFTER DONALD TRUMP
FIRED HIM AND THEN THEY COULD
MAKE THEIR CLAIM ABOUT RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, AND TRY TO IMPEACH HIM.
>> Sean: MARK, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THE GREAT ONE, YOU CAN SEE